les arnaques par email sont très très
très très très très nombreuses et il
faut faire extrêmement attention
personne n'est à l'abri j'en ai parlé il
ya pas longtemps il ya marty qui s'est
fait pirater tout son compte youtube
google à cause d'un email on peut
vraiment savoir le but de cette vidéo
aujourd'hui c'est de revoir un peu de
quelle manière est ce que ces pirates
arrivent jusqu'à vous et de quelle
manière ce qu'ils essayent de vous faire
croire des choses pour reçoit s'emparer
de votre ordinateur en installant un
joli petit cheval de troie soin de
récupérer des données soit vous envoyer
vers un site web corrompus et il faut
faire vachement gaffe mais avant toute
chose ne s'est pas déjà le cas je vous
invite à venir vous abonner à la chaîne
encore un petit bouton rouge que vous
avez qui est juste en bas ici pourquoi
pas parce que je vous parle
effectivement de tests d'ordinateurs de
smartphones de tablettes deux monstres
et compagnie je vous parle surtout de
vous de votre vie numérique des bons
usages et les envoyer une vidéo comme ça
c'est vraiment pour vous donner toutes
les bonnes astuces pour éviter les
déconvenues éviter de se faire à bord et
croyez moi il y en a beaucoup
moi j'en reçois des paquets justement on
va essayer de voir ce qu'il faut éviter
ce qui est extrêmement important vous
vous n'ayez pas de déconvenues à
l'avenir et que vous ne soyez pas piraté
vous est listé pas moins de sept as tu
sois c'est comme ça cette astuce plus
quelques conseils qui vont arriver à la
fin il ya en tout 5 concept ça nous fait
en tout douze chose à regarder ensemble
vous allez voir il ya des choses qu'on
connaît c'est plutôt du bon sens mais ya
certaines choses qu'on n'oublie et c'est
quand même bien de se faire une petite
piqûre de rappel le premier point dans
un e-mail ça va concerner l'expéditeur
vérifier qui vous envoie kelmed je
reçois vachement d'arnac de personnes
qui sont passées pour youtube parce que
mon adresse professionnelle youtube
apparaît dans ma partie à propos sur
youtube pour pouvoir recevoir un des
contacts et bien regarder la parade dans
son email je vois quoi youtube youtube
channel notification je clique alors la
première fait savoir c'est effectivement
si le nom de l'expéditeur correspond
l'e-mail est là que jeanne espèce de
truc ffq sur jean cale à robert f
chronique hell.com donc là tout on le
voit c'est de l'arnaqué
ça sent relativement mauvais faut
vraiment faire extrêmement attention là
c'est pareil en un autre ici là j'ai un
no reply
atl youtube.com et par l e-mail c1 sense
@ toute ma favorite points comme donc là
vraiment on cherche vraiment à se faire
passer pour quelqu'un d'autre est pareil
dans des e-mails perso j'en ai envoyé
jeanne email d'amazon je détiens la zone
mena écrit et si j'en regarde l'e-mail
et bien j'ai amazon
@ sail giorno point com donc voyez c'est
très facile pour ces votre lave de se
faire passer pour une autre entreprise
et si on n'est pas extrêmement vigilant
on voit qui est juste marquer amazon
marne on se fait arnaquer si on sans
confiance on clique on va dans tout ce
qu'à faire on peut rapidement se faire
avoir les arnaques avec les très gros
sites amazon netflix paypal y en a des
tonnes fait vachement gaffe vérifiez
toujours le nom li mail de l'expéditeur
comme ça c'est le premier point il faut
être extrêmement vigilant
le deuxième point qui doit attirer votre
attention sont les fautes d'orthographes
et les erreurs de syntaxe
votre très très vigilant là-dessus
partez du principe qu'une communication
en entreprise
elle est structurée il n'y a pas de
fautes s'est lu relu c'est envoyer ses
clips regard département cet email la
récompense amazon confirme et réclamer
maintenant réclamer la maintenant
réclamer maintenant c'est un peu bizarre
ce courrier électronique vous est
destiné tenter de gagner là y'a pas
particulièrement pote six autres cadeaux
il ya un a majuscule un c majuscule à
cadeau donc vraiment ça ça tient mon
attention et j'en ai reçu un autre mais
qui lui est quand même d'un niveau
vraiment supérieur là là c'est paco est
pas qu il nous écrit des trucs est la
somme dérobée fut 390 pesos mexicains
soit ça soit ça q l'arnaqué à plein nez
mais des fois il ya des textes le on se
rend pas trop compte qu'elle est petite
faute d'orthographe qui se glisse par ci
par là et pour moi fait vachement gaffe
si vous vouliez la moindre faute
d'orthographe vous passez votre chemin
le troisième point c'est le contenu
quand c'est trop beau c'est qu'il ya un
loup lidl point fr dernier rappel pour
confirmer déjà que l'objet de l'e-mail
est très nébuleux c'est très bizarre là
le logo ça ressemble pas au logo de
l'idole alors on voit bien dans l'e-mail
qu'effectivement c'est pas du tout ça
félicitations vous êtes éligible pour
votre récompense a réclamé chez votre
magasin lidl locale ça c'est un truc qui
doit tout de suite attiré votre
attention
quand c'est trop beau c'est qu'il ya un
loup c'est en tout cas je m'applique
dans ma vie leur règle générale quand
c'est trop beau c'est qu'un loup alors
on peut avoir gagné un concours mais
pour avoir aidé au concours il faut
commencer par avoir participé au
concours pour rester vigilants et
gagnait toujours un oeil ouvert là
dessus le quatrième fois c'est toujours
regarder les liens avant de cliquer ne
cliquez jamais sur un lien dans un email
si vous n'êtes pas sûrs du lien vous
allez cliquer regardez on va y retourner
une fois de plus dans ce fameux email de
leader on va survoler la le petit bouton
ok et une fait apparaître en bas j'ai un
business tirer media.com business avec
une grosse faute d'orthographe et j'ai
une espèce de variable d
déjà je vois que suis pas du tout chez
lidl on va faire la même chose avec
l'amazone j'ai un quart à billy points
comme voyez ça craint et si je vends mes
emails potentiellement youtube car déjà
un get started
je survole alors là j'ai bien un truc là
raconte point google sur une
autorisation signing trop access online
gagnetaud kate jack tak tak creator ce
tir et acomptes points comme identifié
ça va me demander je pense de rentrer
mon identifiant et son mot de passe sur
un espèce de sites creator accorde point
com qui n'existe pas puisqu'il ya bien
une application de créateurs mais c'est
une application qui lie à votre compte
google ce site là n'existe pas n'est pas
google si je me fais avoir à rentrer mon
identifiant mot de passe je donne aux
pirates ensuite ils vont venir piraté
mon compte et j'aurais plus que ça rien
là c'est pareil view coronavirus update
et la séparer creator dashboard point
pro et ces trucs là il y en a des tonnes
par année c'est pareil que veuillez
confirmer votre identité félicitations
or on a un email très bullshit vous avez
été choisi parmi 200 personnes qui
organisent notre sondage
amazon regardez-la déjà la police est
pas la même entre sondages et amazon
veuillez confirmer il ya des lettres
majuscules partout votre identité puis
spécifié nous devons envoyer votre
cadeau profitez de votre cadeau nous
espérons vous voir bientôt amazon et là
je me survol j'ai instauré du google
apps sam envoie sur quoi l'un là je vois
pas le bout du lien et regardez-les
ambages un clic ici clic s'écrit en
anglais ici et karim hajji skull est
pareil ça sent vraiment le gros bout
shit fait vraiment ypres à ypres agathe
vérifiez toujours les liens ne cliquez
pas sur un lien ça sent mauvais avant
d'avoir vérifié le cinquième point c'est
toujours se méfier des pièces jointes
n'ouvrez jamais une pièce jointe ci
incluent qui vous parait louche le
sixième point est gelée beaucoup vu avec
les arnaques à youtube
je reçois beaucoup d'e-mails se faisant
passer pour youtube beaucoup tomber dans
la boîte de spam et pendant un temps
elle ne tombez pas dans la boîte de ce
panel arrivé dans ma boîte normale et du
coup ça n'attire pas l'attention puisque
j'avais toutes les arnaques dans la base
comme celle-là est bonne je dis ok ça
peut être youtube fait extrêmement
attention ils les pirates sont toujours
très malin très très très malin et
trouve toujours de nouvelles techniques
pour ne pas tomber dans la boîte span
alors au bout d'un moment elles
finissent par y arriver mais pendant ce
laps de temps vous risquez de vous faire
avoir en faisant confiance à votre
système anti spam qui ne reconnaît pas
encore ce type d'arnaqué
donc malgré tout rester toujours
vigilant même s'il email n'apparaît pas
dans le dossier spam le
tiens point on connaît un peu plus
aujourd'hui c'est attention aux emails
qu'ils sont écrits en anglais et si vous
avez de l'anglais là typiquement vous
l'avez vu je voulais montrer vous avez
un petit message avec un clic qui est
écrit en bas c'est tout petit c'est
caché vous n'allez pas avoir un beau
d'anglais dans un message français et de
la même manière si vous avez un animal
qui tout écrit en anglais méfiez vous
alors si vous êtes en france si vous
êtes aux états unis en angleterre où je
ne sais où vous pouvez recevoir des
e-mails l'anglais howard et services
internationaux vous pouvez recevoir des
emails anglais mais imaginez par exemple
vous avez un compte paypal et que vous
recevez un email de paypal en anglais si
votre compte paypal et configure en
français vous n'avez aucune raison de
recevoir un email en anglais méfiez vous
reste la plus extrême en vision sur ce
point huitième point c'est de recouper
un peu tout ça il faut vraiment qu une
cohérence entre le nom de l'expéditeur
entre lee mail de l'expéditeur avec un
message hyper clean et les actions qu'on
vous demande derrière si par exemple
vous recevez un email de paypal paypal
vous dit vérifiez vos coordonnées
bancaires qu'on vous demande de rentrer
sur un site et de marquer vos
coordonnées bancaires ne voyais ça
craint si vous arrivez de la même
manière sur un site et que vous vous
dites ok c'est bon ça craint pas c'est
vraiment le site vous arrivez sur le
site si on vous demande de rentrer votre
identifiant et votre mot de passe
fait extrêmement attention et maintenant
on arrive dans les quelques conseils qui
vont me permettre de vous donner
quelques petites astuces et quelques
clés pour éviter de vous faire avoir là
dessus le premier point c'est d'être
extrêmement pragmatique demandez vous
pourquoi on vous contacte quel est le
but derrière si les choses sont trop
belles une fois de plus méfiez-vous jeu
pas pourquoi on irait vous offrir
beaucoup d'argent des gros cadeau si
vous n'avez pas participé comme ça par
hasard c'est très très très très bizarre
sourit vraiment extrêmement pragmatique
et ça pour moi c'est premier point c'est
extrêmement important qui nous
contactent et dans quel but le deuxième
point c'est vérifié vérifier vérifier
pensez toujours à vérifier
l'email le message comme je voulais
décrire vérifier vérifier vérifier c'est
extrêmement important
le troisième point ne donnez jamais vos
coordonnées bancaires si vous arrivez
sur un site et qu'on vous demande
justement donner vos coordonnées
bancaires numéro de carte bleue mots de
passe identifiants ne fait pas ne le
faites surtout pas ce qui est
extrêmement important à ce moment là
c'est si vous avez confiance et vous
arrivez sur un site genre paypal qui
vous dit rentrez votre identifiant et
votre mot de passe est validé
vérifiez d'abord dans l'url http s
toujours le s pour la sécurité
www.lesoir.be paypal.com et que ce ne
soit pas avec une fois
d'orthographe de l'aide d'un verser dans
le paypal pour être sûr que vous tombiez
bien sûr le vrai site ce qu'il faut
faire à ce moment-là si par exemple
paypal vous écrivez vous demande de
mettre à coordonnées bancaires à jour
vous ne cliquez pas sur les liens vous
allez vous même directement sur paypal
et vous regardez c'est à ce moment là
vous n'avez pas une notification qui
vous demande de mettre à jour vos
coordonnées bancaires
s'il n'y a pas eu notification si tu
n'as pas le besoin et comme ce moment
vous risquez pas vous faire un hacker
quatrième point méfiez vous des sites
qui ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau
sites sur lesquels vous avez l'habitude
d'aller je vous reprends une fois de
plus l'exemple de paypal imaginez vous
êtes un pirate vite comment est ce que
je vais faire mes jean-yves ont cliqué
ils vont arriver sur mon site simon site
ressemble absolument pas au site
officiel de paypal ou de youtube ou
compagnie et bien vous allez pas avoir
confiance c'est pas parce que votre site
ressemble exactement au site que ça veut
dire que c'est celui là vérifiez bien
l'url et de manière un peu général
passer par votre moteur de recherche
vous tapez être directement l'adresse
dans votre navigateur pour arriver sur
le site
il ne passait pas par les liens du mail
pour justement éviter de tomber dans ce
genre d'armes et puis le cinquième point
s'est vérifié vérifier vérifier on ne
vérifie jamais assez vous vérifierez
jamais assez pour être sûr de ne pas
vous faire arnaquer et croyez moi c'est
extrêmement important
voilà pour ces points la plupart sont
connus dites moi d'ailleurs vous
lesquels vous connaissez lesquels vous
appliquez est-ce que vous avez des
conseils en plus à donner parce que ça
peut être extrêmement important qui a
probablement des points que j'ai oublié
de spécifier que j'ai pas vu et sur
lesquels on peut vraiment se faire
arnaquer dites moi c'est d'ailleurs ça
vous est arrivé vous de vous faire
arnaquer à cause de vos emails sur des
identifiants mots de passe sur des
comptes qui ont été compromis sur des
données bancaires quel type de données
vous avez perdu vous êtes pharma qui
marquera tout ça en bas en commentaire
ça permettra d'enrichir le débat est de
voir justement comment est-ce que les
pirates s'y sont pris pour vous avoir
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
intéressé qu elle vous permettra de
déjouer quelques arnaques sur internet
marque pas tout ça bien évidemment pas
en commenter à 4 ou extrêmement
rapidement pour continua par l'état qui
croyez moi il ya plein de choses qui
arrivent ça va beaucoup d'amour a très
vite à bientôt
[Musique]